what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite Duo sinee and Sophia
this is the episode we've been waiting
to shoot because we get to talk about
our Halloween party spooky SC you
skeletons okay we are aware that this is
coming out a week into November so yes
we know Halloween has passed but let us
have our moment yeah we want to recap it
we've we've sat on it for the last two
days and we have a lot to say yes a lot
last episode we were pretty much in the
worst mood ever and I don't know if you
guys could tell we were actually
considering scrapping that episode cuz
we just had nervous sweats the whole
time about this party oh yeah I mean our
brains were off our head because we were
thinking about the pricing the planning
if anyone was going to show up if it our
because the first has to set the tone
I'm sorry if we're saying this is an
annual Stallone Halloween party it
better be the best goddamn start if the
first one is bad no one would want to
come no one wants to go that's the thing
we had one in LA and it really did well
but we're in a new city people new new
Energy new personalities I don't know
New Yorkers as well as New Yorkers do so
we really were um I have to say though
it was pretty ambitious for us to move
to the city 6 months ago and try to fill
out a room of 300 people we I maybe have
three friends that's also just just say
this um we thought it was only a 220
person space and ended up being um to
the max like 350 so now we're thinking
right 20 minutes before we walk in we're
like we need to find another 100 people
100 people we have to find 100 people
okay leading up to the party cinee and I
were
actually I I think I I was like breaking
out the day of of the party oh yeah I
had like almost hives on my chest I was
so nervous I stayed in bed to prepare my
body for this until 300 p.m. no I took
nyol didn't move and Advil p.m. and I
took melatonin yeah did I sleep
literally not an hour not even an hour
no it was it really bad it was
terrifying but I was so excited to just
finally put my costume on you know when
a kid on their first day of school has
their uniform light on their bed and
they just have it on top of their duvet
and they're waiting to put it on the
next day that was me oh yeah oh I
couldn't wait oh I've been staring at my
costume for 2 months straight and I'm
like I'm going to wear the [__] out of
this out because let's be real there are
two types of girls on Halloween like the
funny sort of silly or scary route and
then there's the super [__] Regina
George route I live for the [__] rout
okay listen I'm all about being scared
and weird and creepy but there's
something about there's almost a freedom
of just being out in lingerie and no one
can judge you for it no one can judge
you for being a [__] for a night because
you're in character because you're not
you I'm a beer girl Stine's a maid can't
get can't get mad at that but I actually
all my friends were asking me leading up
to the party like I want to be um scream
I want to be um Voldemort and I
literally said to them I love you guys
and I totally think that's hilarious but
can you actually not sopia was like we
need hot people we need hot we got to
have some hot energy and my friends
showed up they like even your friends
everyone came in it was epic it was
actually the funnest night I think I've
had in a long time first we
hired scary actors to jump out at
everyone from Every turn that they took
so that was amazing people were
terrified before even walking in but
let's just say we filled up the space
people stayed fully packed till 4:30 in
the morning the DJ was easily the best
investment we had that guy was going at
Banger after Banger throwback after
throwback after 2 there literally wasn't
a hiccup in the music and the drinks
were free so everyone was just going
going crazy I have to say you know it's
a good night when you have no idea what
time it is and you check your phone and
you go oh my God it's 3:40 in the
morning I didn't see 90% of the people I
invited I I don't remember any we saw
Chris hold on hold on I have to let's
let's ask Chris so we invited producer
Chris to the Halloween party and when I
saw you on the Dance Floor I feel like
my soul left my body I was like yes like
you made it okay what did you think
honestly you can tell the truth did you
tell the truth it was great it was like
completely packed out you guys were all
like nervous ahead of time you thought
it wasn't going to be packed out it was
like very packed and it was a lot of fun
the music was great see wait how how
late did you stay I think till like 3:00
3:30 stop I love that let's go so many I
think that most people started drifting
away at like 3: 3:30
but it was still by 40 when we were
there still going off no it was
fantastic it's also another good sign
that it was a party when everyone ends
up at a 24-hour Deli at 5:00 a.m. yes
that's a good party I got so many texts
from people from cats saying that they
the entire actually most of the place
was packed in people from the party all
in Halloween costumes at 4:30 in the
morning that you know is a good party um
I would say that other than that the
only thing that cine remember how we
said cinee invited a lot of prospects to
this party God so I I walked into this
party actually having zero like there
wasn't one guy that I was actively
searching and to be honest I was kind of
relieved by that I wasn't focus on it so
Ste took it upon herself to invite
everybody that she had been talking to
in the last six months listen it was
ambitious because if the roles were
reversed and I was ghosted I don't think
I would show up to his party either but
let's just say I was quickly humbled
because no one showed up wait literally
except a banana there's one banana suit
man the banana guy was your guy yes I
got a picture with
him wait you're going to die you're
going to die I okay I invited this guy
who oh God he's going to hear this but
whatever he's like stupid hot okay he's
stupid hot yeah I didn't think he would
show up he said I'm going to dress as a
banana so when I saw this giant peel in
the middle of the Dance Floor I go holy
cow he's a banana and I was so drunk at
one point of the night this is when I
knew I was way worse than Sophia because
I get to a level I'm very heady we say
this I'm very headyy when I drink yeah
very strategic I don't like to let
myself get loose don't know why no she
never does like I I'm more of the one
that is like you know yes man like I'll
I'll go for it if everyone's vibing I'll
Vibe she's more restricted in that way I
drank an Unholy amount to the point
where I had Sophia even coming up to me
at one point saying what are you doing
you look dumb and I'll tell you why I
look dumb I took it upon myself myself
to go up on the elevated DJ booth take
off my costume put on the banana suit
and I was a banana for a good 40 minutes
of the party so I walk behind the DJ
booth and I find her and she's fully
sweating wearing this banana suit he's
wearing her apron from the costume and I
Lally pull sinee aside and I said sinee
I love you so much you look foul she's
like you look dumb I was like piking I
love you but like you actually no let me
tell you I was like hands down ass up a
banana souping her hair was everywhere
her face was sweaty and she's all you
see is her face in the banana suit like
I'm not I'm not trying to rain on
anyone's parade but he was so
good-looking and they're like flirting
I'm like sis this is not the time
flirting looking like this see that's
the issue too because this person is so
handsome right you would think oh I want
to look my best as well no I had my hair
sticking to my face in a banana suit it
was bad the next day was so funny no
you're forgetting how I left the night
how so we pretty much closed the place
down all the lights are on and I really
wanted all of the decor in the club I
want to killer and I was running around
the street and Sophia couldn't get me in
a cab I was trying to grab her I'm like
you look insane so Sophia gets in a cab
and I run away I grab a cab with my
cousin and I'm like we're going home it
is almost 5:00 a.m. let's go to bed
she's like no I want pizza I go you I
know you you actually want your bed like
I get in the car she goes why do you
always tell me what to do and I go you
know what screw you peace out go eat a
[__] pizza with banana boy and I leave
and guess what not even 20 minutes later
as I walk into the room I
hear I didn't get the pizza she didn't
get the pizza she came home and we ate
puffins but um it was funny because I
think what the the best part was was
that um the next
day I for some reason woke up with zero
hangover zero like I might I was
exhausted like I you could I could feel
tired like my body was a bit lethargic
feeling but I was not no headache you
did two things that really grinded my
gears all right okay you like that one
Chris one what the whole night you were
saying I'm not getting drunk because I'm
only doing
shots what I said to sinee she's like
how are you um not hung over I said
sinee I two bottles of Pedialite before
going and all I did was shots in water
so basically I'm a genius and but like
you still had at least 10 shots you're
still going to get drunk but I hydrated
CU you got a Gatorade doesn't mean can I
drink so much water that night so that's
the thing that was my attack and so I
woke up like good morning everyone sinee
comes out of bed her right eye was
swollen shut she couldn't see out of it
I there's nothing worse there's nothing
worse than when you feel like absolute
ass you feel like death and Sophia comes
running into my room good morning I feel
so good I don't even feel hung over my
left eye you want some coffee I just
finished making it you guys my left eye
was swollen shut I couldn't see out of
it both of my knees the whole kneecaps
right now black black from bruises
didn't know I fell I I have weird marks
in my body I don't know where they came
I was so unwell that I was sitting on my
toilet for like 30 minutes and I took it
like I fell asleep like I was just like
I don't feel good I haven't been like
that in so long I was like so good I'm
like put on my outfit I put on little
earrings but we sat on the couch and we
pretty much were like in a coma sitting
on that couch we looked at each other
and we were like was that party fun we
can't really tell we weren't really we
we were a little bit mobile throughout
the party but we weren't we don't know
we didn't really ask many people and we
kind of were saying oh [__] maybe it was
bad like maybe the decorations were
cheesy maybe the then you get in your
head you get the what is it we got the
Sunday scary yeah like we had heard from
anybody after we saw some of the post
like oh God we don't know we get a text
from the guy who helped us plan it and
he's like oh here's a link to all the
photos cuz they had a floating
photographer and it was just for us to
have and we were looking through it okay
the best way I can describe going
through these photos
was it is the exact same ending of The
Hangover when they have the photo
montage yes it really was and you start
and they go and they're holding up the
camera and they go oh [__] and we're
going through and it was insan looking
like everyone looked like they were
sweaty taking shots screaming at the
camera it was it looked like the best
party ever and that's when c i we looked
it we go we did a good job we did a Joe
we did a Joe we did it we did it until
next year I was literally telling Sophia
on the walk here go like I wish it was
next year already I know she was like we
got to plan it we already know we're
going to do better and this and this and
that was look I will say that was one of
the harder things we've done in a little
bit is planning such a big party for now
300 people that we didn't realize but I
now understand why people referred to BR
as Bridezillas oh yeah because not
saying it's the same thing by any means
but the pressure of planning a party
like I was we just started getting angry
for no reason well it's also we invested
a lot of money into it so we're like we
really need this to go well cuz then it
it's going to be worth nothing yeah and
it was worth everything every dime every
nickel especially the DJ we do need to
start picking up some shift somewhere
though I know oh my God we got to pay
that back up us somewhere I got it I
can't I can't do that great yeah so the
next day we get some hangover waffles I
too mhm didn't feel good we running
people from on the street that went to
the party and they're like that was epic
and we're like yes like it the city and
people were texting like we got to go
next year I'm like but what was so
alarming on top of my hangover was
listen I'm not a very touchy Fey person
like I don't love hugs yeah ever since I
was a kid like see I'm cringing right
now I just don't love being touched I
love hugs like I will give everyone a
hug I I love I love like holding
people's hands like so the oh yeah this
is actually so weird Stine's never
touched me before by the way like okay
you're making it sound like I'm not
making it sound like anything she's
physically never hugged me like she's
literally never put her arm around me
she's never held my hand yes when it's
your
birthday not even then not not even on
my birthday she's never touched me
before the day of the party we're
walking down the street and I'm just on
my phone I feel someone put an arm
around me and I look to the side and I
see cinee and I go no I'll I'll explain
it in my head it was one of those
moments where I knew she wasn't really
thinking about it and I just wanted to
embrace her and just be like look we
made it this far we did a good job we
did everything we could and she
immediately looks at me and goes what is
there is your ex over there what are you
doing is there Paparazzi why are you
doing this I L asked her I was like are
we are we hiding from someone like why
are you touching me I and was crying in
the middle of the street I actually was
so freaked out at the fact she was
touching me that I didn't believe that
it was for genuine purposes she thought
either we were hiding from an ex or
there was a photographer there was
papazzi CU there there would be no way
there's no way I would touch you without
those two things being there you've
never touch me period so I'm like okay
there's no way that she's doing this at
the kindness of her heart and I think
that's probably the last time you're
ever going to touch it cuz if that's my
reaction by the way I'm trying something
new I'm proud of you baby steps baby
steps I tried don't reject my efforts I
mean you just give this party has
changed me I'm a changed woman oh really
though okay okay well I think next year
we're going to vet out some better
prospects for both of us and not I know
I'm actually shocked we didn't kiss
anyone um I'm not that shocked for me I
there was I was just not you were
hanging out with that pirate all night
was he a pirate I don't know yeah he was
just following me around the time he was
so annoying I'm not going to lie you
know he came up to me you know what he
said to me it was so weird cuz he's like
a Florida guy I'm not really sure who he
is we haven't spoken once didn't say
anything he comes right up to me and he
goes if you play pickle ball you're a
loser we only do tennis around here it's
230 I'm like hold on who are you what
are you supposed to be dressed as what
do you have against pickle ball and like
your hair is too quaffed like get the
[__] out of my face hair is pretty
perfect I'm not going to lie it was it
was very much like like who says that
stranger yeah it was a little bit random
yeah that was my that was like my semi-
Prospect I guess but now didn't work out
no kisses but next year we'll figure
something out next year next year oh
well good job I'm not touching you wow
that was really embarrassing anyone
watched
that I hate you for that one um okay so
C and I just to change
subjects this is very much obviously not
Niche everyone's talked about this but
we thought it'd be funny to talk about
our own but you know the Roman Empire
the whole Trend that everyone's talking
about like oh for guys it means that
they think about the Roman Empire how
often do you think about the Roman
Empire actually no not I was going to
say wow once a week probably once a week
once a week so yeah so that's the thing
like basically it's like what guys or
girls think about very consistently
that's a bit shocking to people yes but
for girls apparently like this is the so
many good ones yeah but for girls it's
losing a best friend it's like that one
girlfriend that you were so so close
with that you had a falling out with
that that's our Roman Empire like I
could care less about breaking up with a
guy I could care less about anything
else but I truly think if there was that
one instance or scenario with you losing
someone that was so close to you like a
friendship that was so close to you and
you I think about it like twice three
times a week that's my Roman Empire cuz
it just like eats you up it hits you in
a place where you're like I never saw my
life without this person and now they're
not in my life it's the relationship
between a friend and a boyfriend or just
even another like romantic relationship
it's so different it's so different I
don't even know if I wouldn't even say
deeper but there is like that horrid
loss of like losing a friend especially
when you've confided in them about
everything and it's like that person you
think is going to be there for your
wedding and well I would argue most best
friends I'm closer with then my partner
for sure think about it like you tell
each other the nitty-gritty you tell
each other the gross things the like
things that you wouldn't need to say to
your boyfriend that's yeah I guess it
dependent on like the person and the
relationship but 100% And I also think
when it comes to losing a best friend
it's not like a subtle losing it's
always some sort of like travesty with
with whether it's like about a guy or
it's about like something that you guys
disagree on or maybe they have a
boyfriend that you hate and they love or
whatever it is it's not like an easy
breakup and so that's like definitely my
Roman Empire I think I have like one I
always think about God what if it worked
cuz I would also think that finding a
genuine friendship is so hard oh it's so
so hard if you have just one special
person in your life you're you're good
100% because I'm right now like dating
for friendships mhm men literally just
dating for a girlfriend yeah and that is
more intimidating to me yeah and I'm
putting in more work than I would going
on a date with a guy because yeah you
have to really see first first and
foremost girls are so different than
boys like you could literally bat an
eyelash and they're like I love you
doesn't matter girls you really have to
see if like your personality is align
the way you guys sort of date is align
like your moral is align the way you
like to go out is align like there's so
many other layers lers to like a
friendship don't align with like right
so if you find one and then you lose one
that's devastating know and you know
what's so interesting that I like for
part of some of my like friendships that
have ended and I've lost my friends I've
realized that with a lot of those people
that you're close with why is it that
sometimes girlfriends that you think are
really close to like I've had
girlfriends in my life that I've
considered like sisters at that point
but I realize now as I'm older that they
only supported me when I was feeling
horrible if that makes sense I've had
relationships in my life where I've had
girlfriends that were there at my lowest
that like want to support me tell me
that I'm amazed with that stuff but when
I'm at my highest I've had girlfriends
that completely would say they if I
walked into the room and I looked pretty
they wouldn't compliment me but I would
always compliment them if I did
something well they wouldn't really
acknowledge it it it was like I've had
friends that only were there for their
low points or the low points and you
kind of take a step back and you realize
like that's not really a good friend
like that's not someone that you want to
have a run that's a pretty toxic
relationship because that means that
that person only likes to give advice or
they feel good if they know that you're
not doing good yeah and I feel like
which is strange because it is hard to
almost find someone that is so excited
for your wins just like you are for
theirs I think that's a tall tale sign
that someone's just not out for your
best interest girls are tricky like that
too yeah that's what I'm saying girls
are just we're all just jealous people
by Nature like we're jealous of silly
stupid things MH but I saw this one
video and this is like sort of relating
to what you're saying but not really
they said this is the way you can tell
if you have a really good friend in your
life someone that genuinely has your
best interest yeah if you have gorgeous
hair like gorgeous long you've always
been known to have this staple beautiful
hair right and you go up to your friend
and you
say I want to cut bangs and then a bonus
I also want to cut a bob short bob and
bangs if they tell you do it you would
look so good not your friend if they
would if they tell you oh my God you
would look horrible why would you ruin
your beautiful hair that's a real friend
they have your best interest oh Jesus
they have your best interest you know in
in all honestly I've had people say I
should cut bangs and I have my hair what
did I say to you you said never do it I
have your best interest you do have my
best interest that's true you just
support me at my high and low points I
think that's a tall tail sign that
someone's not looking out for you and so
I feel like a lot of people for real I
think that when you're at your and you
have a girlfriend that does that and
doesn't support you on your high moments
you think that they're doing it at the
goodness of their heart which I think
that obviously it's really important to
have people do it both ways like it's
great that someone's there for you for
your low but not just that like you
can't have someone that is just
supporting you when you're bad like you
need to have someone that's also
supporting you at your high you know how
they say it hurt people hurt and you
sort of I don't know I think inity thing
sometimes I think when someone's feeling
down it's easy to connect with people
that are also in that low point in their
life and then you guys can kind of just
support each other in that that weird
space so it is hard when someone is up
here and someone's not doing well when
you're not doing well I could see why it
would be difficult to be a cheerleader
for someone who has their life figured
out at the moment yeah I understand that
but I also think that you know no matter
what you want someone to do the best
that if you love them like I even if I'm
not doing great I always want to make
sure that you are happy and you are
doing well and you are like obviously
insecurity and self-doubt and you know
the Whata ifs com to your head but I
mean at the end of the day I don't want
to see you fail like I don't want to see
you crash and burn I don't want to see
you you
don't sometimes if you're annoying me
not a friend not a friend I'll my Roman
Empire is what that girl that sings that
song water Tay ta Tay ta that's your
Roman Empire you think about that every
single day I think so I'm not going to
lie she actually has played that song 18
times throughout the apartment I always
hear like once like literally every hour
I hear make me swear there's something
so ethereal about this woman I don't
even know I call her a woman I looked
her up born in 2003 she's 21 and can
move like that her face looks like that
God people that are at this age right
now like people that are born in the
2000s just trip me up they look like
they're 30 she's God's favorite I wore
she's so pretty at her age I was wearing
a flash drive with poems and my car keys
like that was that was by lanyard her
age she is like moving her hips she's
beautiful like I I just don't know how I
love seeing on Tik Tok though all of the
girls that are um playing the song in
front of their boyfriends to see if they
look over because every girl on Tik Tok
is twerking to that song Now by way I
would look over I know I would look over
I'm trying to think what mine would be
football players okay that's duh okay I
mean you can't okay you literally just
went out with one I kind of kind you did
okay I did I wouldn't say football
players I think 247 like drooling but
you went out with one and then the other
day you were like look at the new skim
campaign with all the football players
and guess who answered over the cross
the room saying Sophia I get it now she
said I get it listen look do I want to
marry one no but I don't I don't I would
not be a good wag I I can't handle the
the traveling the distance and all the
chicks wearing the jerseys and they're
chasing them I end into it but you saw
after we saw the nickb so I with the
scams if you know what I'm talking about
Nick Bosa Kim Kardashian knew what she
was
doing Nick
Bosa I don't even know what team he
plays for I don't know what position he
is I don't know what color his jersey is
and I don't care R I don't
care why does he look like that he just
looks gorgeous I don't get how some
people are built like that I don't know
either I don't get it I don't I don't
see them walking around here speaking of
belt did you see that Kim Kardashian is
releasing a bra with built-in nipples
yeah I love it is that no of course you
like it who would ever wear that in
public me why okay for example the other
night we were going out to dinner right
and I had this dress on and I was like o
it would be kind of cute if there was a
little nipp and I was trying I was like
trying to trying to to wake him up
didn't work okay if I had the bra so
dumb it's kind of Genius it's so so you
there's certain dresses and outfits that
you would wear because the nips would be
out and they would look better let's
let's refer back to my list this has to
be like a a joke like I don't think
she's being serious about it let's refer
back to my list in March when I said
these are the things I want to start
doing when I moved to New York to create
a new identity one thing on the list was
nips out all
right and in a way I feel almost
protected cuz technically they're not my
nipples um they're St
ioam and they're actually perfect
looking I I did see the the ad like they
were perfectly positioned but can you
imagine I'm not lie can you imagine the
scenario you go on a date you wear it
you come
home and he sees you come over with the
guy and he takes his shirt off and he's
like what he go in the hell is that he
puts it on he's like I'm confused it's
just it's just alarming it's kind of
like it's like the fake hair like how do
you get out of that like he looks at
your real he looks at your real ones
bring my fake hair again I didn't bring
in your fake hair I was that you just
brought in your fake one damn it I know
but I would say that that would probably
be mine and yeah I did go out with a
football player why don't you tell
people about that well actually I'll
I'll talk about this so I this was my
first Instagram DM date like I've had
DMS before but I am not the person that
likes to go through my Instagram and
answer people like I'm just not like I I
just it's just I not that it doesn't
work it's totally work worked so many
celebrities have done it um I just am
hesitant on it I don't know i' rather
meet you in person but um he was cute
and so I was like okay he was exactly
your type yeah he was my type he was
very much my type and I was like you
know what one time we're in New York
City he said he's in town let me just go
on a date there's no strings attached we
end up having planned a date in Florida
cuz I was ending up working there and he
ended up going there cuz it was an off
weekend for him I don't know what that
means I guess he was playing that
weekend or something and he was like
yeah I'm actually going to be in Miami
so we go on this date it was really fun
I mean look nothing's coming from it
because like nothing happened it was
easy fun good good guy what I will tell
you which was very interesting was that
I was getting burner accounts from girls
that he has gone out with saying stay
away from him it was horrible like
things like that and like and you could
tell it was like from girls that had
followed him or whatever and it was I
got like four or five um and I've never
had that before and I was like how did
first of all they know and then second
of all um I just like that's this is
also the reason why I don't use DM dates
and like things like that like I I I
rather go off with a not famous person
like I don't I don't like it unless it's
like someone that looks like Nick Bosa
then we're going to answer the DM answer
the DM but like that was pretty wild
like I just I I mean look do I listen
and take it seriously no I ignore it but
it was I just have never had that before
people like stay away I was like what
the hell like please take them like I
don't you feel like a little bit cool
though no like hearing like people
thrash on no I mean like it was well
like you're a little special like o I'm
the girl that they're threaten by yeah
kind I guess no no not really okay but
it was a good date um he's nice guy not
going to work out but uh yeah it was
just very interesting to see that happen
because I was never had that happen
before well I have a date tonight she
does oh I'm so excited about this and
I'm a little alarmed by it why because I
thought he was saying this as a
joke and then he just sent me um my
ticket for tonight I was okay with just
going to dinner really yeah he's taking
me to a haunted house no way that's
cis's love language is people that scare
her but but in bloody costumes no no
that's wrong I like scary movies I don't
like haunted houses that's [__] you
literally said to me and I quote so
let's go through a haunted house this
week well if I went with you it would be
funny cuz I get to see you terrorized I
the scariest thing I've ever watched was
marle me watching a dog die was
depressing I can't watch anything scary
but the problem is sop I'm going to be
terrified and how do I scare like I'm so
obviously he's confident in the fact
that he's taking you want go oh I'm so
excited to hear about this next week
let's see this is so good you have to do
it you know what she did to me the other
day speaking of like movies and scary
things she was going to go out to get
some groceries or something and she's
left a movie on she's like hey just I I
finished watching this it's black phone
I'm horrified of scary movies she just
left the scariest movie on and there was
like dead demonic kids in the corner in
the film I'm like why would you leave me
alone in the room in the middle of the
night watching black phone with Ethan
Hawk is it called black phone yeah but
it's not scary don't be a baby there's a
guy with a mask that kidnaps children
and kills them in his basement how is
that not scary he's taking me to a place
called nightmare
dollhouse
that I just wanted some sushi I just I
was okay with just getting sushi that
literally sounds like my nightmare dolls
haunted house [__] and a boy remember
dad when we were little used to
terrorize us with dolls my dad that's
what I'm saying my dad when we were
growing up thought that um instead of
giving us a Barbie like a regular child
toy porcel creepy dolls you'd get these
glass made porcelain Russian dolls were
beautifully crafted but as a little girl
terrifying cuz they would blink well you
know when you lay them down they fall
asleep their eyes closed eyes up and
they like open so when we were little he
we'd share a room and he'd wait till we
went to bed or falling asleep and then
he'd put the dolls in the doorway and go
good night and make the dolls talk one
time he put them in our bed bed he
tucked them into bed and then we turned
over and they were like looking at us
scaring us and then one time he like he
opened the door we were asleep and he
crawled into our room and our beds were
right next to each other so right
between us he literally our faces are
right near the edge of the bed and he
put like the finger like touching our
nose to wake us up and he go hello so
scary it like at 2: a.m. we're he's like
eight years old that's crazy he's crazy
speaking of slot he has his documentary
coming out yeah very proud of him he has
a documentary on Netflix coming out am I
a little bitter um yeah I wasn't asked
to be in it yeah a little bit yeah I
mean we have the best accounts of Sly
like we can say we can drop a lot of tea
maybe that's why he didn't want us he
probably he like they're going to talk
way too much about it no it's all about
his life and stuff I'm really excited to
see it I haven't seen it yet so it's
actually about his work which is really
cool yes and apparently he he spells a
lot more than uh we were like assuming
mom said that he was much more
vulnerable than she had thought oh no I
know but it's like family life which is
so I'm very curious to see that I
actually I I wouldn't want a documentary
about myself I would want a movie about
myself who would play
you um I would have probably like Blake
Lively I'm trying to think who's no I'd
have like Margot Robie all right let's
do realistic thank you excuse me who is
who is blonde hair and brown eyes that
would work
well maybe I'm em ratowski for you I'm
going to give you a really good one no
she is acsh no Emily ratowski is am I
saying her name right Emily rowski no no
I want like
um like
a I don't know actually I don't know any
actors I know I'm like blanking all
action I dad honestly D dad with a wig
would probably play me the best cuz
everyone says I have the same face as
him that actually is very true I think
that could work out really well
can I play me in your film Sophia I play
myself one time Sophia was trying to act
and pursue acting oh holy [__] that was
hor she was so bad this is the funniest
thing ever so she got an
audition she got an audition and she was
so nervous to do in front of the family
that she kicked me out she kicked
Scarlet out so she just had my mom and
dad doing the lines with her in the room
oh my God I'm remembering which one
you're talking about and there's this
scene in the scene that she was uh
taping for yeah she was drinking like
out of a flask yeah I was supposed to be
like in a guy's car drinking out of a
flask and she after about 40 takes my
dad said you know what let's actually
fill the flask because she's so bad and
nervous right now let's just fill the
flask cuz maybe as the takes go on
she'll loosen up she ends up finishing
an entire flask because she still
couldn't even get it and she the last
like time I was doing it I was slur slur
I was like I need to get out of this car
right now everyone's like all right so
like your we have to find this audition
my face is flushed it was no that's
never going to see the light of day that
was really bad come on I was hammered
during that audition and thankfully it
was in the Comforts of my own home
surrounded by my mom and dad point being
this is why I would never have you play
me I think I could I could no no no I
would play myself I can play myself I
don't know if you could do that either I
feel like if I had to say my own lines
that I would actually say I would but
mean yeah it would be pretty bad yeah
I'm not good at a lot of things like
that acting is not one of I can talk
like
this that other than that no I can't do
it I think we need to wrap this show up
okay
cool I I still feel um a little drunk in
the brain yeah I have not caught up in
my sleep at all night I'm not doing
great I actually slept in this um and
there's makeup all over it but well we
actually decided Well I decided and
she's going to join me on this we're
doing sober
November yeah I don't think she'll
actually follow through with it but I am
I'll try and I'm going to try to go
gluten-free but you don't have to gluten
free you're not a first of all first of
all first of all don't get me started on
gluten right now what's what's with you
and gluten this is triggering why I'm
going gluten-free how all the sudden
we'll say in 2015 everyone was gluten
intolerance you mean from 2012 and
before then all the way to BC no one had
a gluten intolerance and now everyone's
gluten- free soy free nutree fun free
like agree with are all these allergies
you how many cavemen had gluten
intolerances like no where did this
start I people are say that the food is
just getting worse and now everyone's
getting affected or we just didn't know
about or maybe it's because we poison
our bodies with alcohol every weekend
and then eat piz maybe that's why we
don't feel our best I don't know but I'm
trying I'm going to try to go alcohol
free gluten- free and boy
free right I can do Boy
free I'm working hard on something I'm
doing a little side project this month
actually I walked though if it goes well
this will be a great story if it goes
poorly you'll probably see me crying I
actually walked into your room this
morning to return one of your pillows
did you see my little notes you had a
checklist on your bed and I of course I
read it of course I read it did you see
the first
one can I just repeat the checklist it's
not revealing anything you're just so
you're so no because you're so cringy
but I love that you do this I just like
this is so
to myself I go on her bed and there's a
big checklist and there's only it's a
huge piece of paper only four things on
the checklist first one says phase
two what does that mean phase two of
what of my Mastermind plan next one was
edit the podcast okay next one was do
something with a line that you want to
start and then the next one was write
letter and now I told her to do this
this morning because Sophia's very into
manifestation she's very big on if you
put things from pen to paper and lock it
in your drawer something will come of it
yeah so she was just like write this
letter out I'm not going to give anyone
any details until like until my until I
commence face but basically the letter
is going to
entail what she wants in the next month
or two to happen concerning her love
life in general and it's it's something
where I would going out there and going
to some person or some or some place but
you're being very inconspicuous right
now I can't say it but let's just say
basically it's you know when they say
for like manifesting you have to say
like it's happening at that moment so
basic I'm like writing it like as it's
happening and so I wrote yeah wrote why
did
you I didn't think you would actually do
a checklist I'm sorry I love you I did
commence phase three an hour ago and I
am losing what's so funny about you
Sophia is this checklist is is not even
necessary to write down because it's so
small no write letter there there was um
do Book Club reviews answer my emails it
was update the the pitch deck for a a
line I want to start okay so but but the
first and last one were really funny and
I so embarrassed I Knew by the way I had
a feeling I left it on my bed cinee
doesn't walk into my room often so I was
like I don't think she'll see this
that's actually not true I only use your
shower when you're not home oh yeah by
the way I walked into my bathroom and I
was I was like why is my shower so like
why is it wet I don't like my shower I
know I have Scarlet was using my shower
our little sister and says that I'm
basically a Sephora Spa yeah I have
everything you want like any product any
hair thing I have it and it's so much
fun if you don't know what you want to
use it's ridiculous it's so good it's
ridiculous so okay we'll update you guys
about this phase three and I'll tell you
um about my haunted house Daye what the
[__] what the [__] there's a lot coming
up next episode Okay so terapia episode
we're going to start doing listener
questions make sure you go to the
ratings and review section of Apple
podcast leave your question in the
comment section you give us a five star
review or else we're not going to answer
it and you know you guys Apple Spotify
and YouTube all the platforms we're
using um and also follow us on Ticky
talk and Instagram we post a lot of
clips and they're really fun if you want
to see some shorts and yeah s out it's
all of them so this banana we'll see you
next Tuesday goodbye happy Halloween not
really not really